Україні потрібно оголосити дефолт, рівняння на Грецію,
вважає олігарх Ігор Коломойський, який нещодавно провернувся в Україну.
В інтерв'ю британській газеті Financial Times він заявив, цитата,
"ми маємо ставитися до наших кредиторів, як Греція. Це приклад для України".
Оголошення Україною дефолту не вирішить проблем, а створить нові, вважають експерти.
Перший і найголовніший наслідок дефолту, який тягне за собою всі інші - це знецінення гривні.
В разі дефолту курс національної валюти щодо євро і долара "просяде" не на кілька гривень,
а в рази, запевняють економісти.
За найбільш песимістичними прогнозами, ледь не до 100 гривень за долар.
А за оптимістичними - до 40-50 гривень за один "зелений".
Якщо буде дефолт, Україна суттєво втратить свої позиції в рейтингах світових агентств і, відповідно,
не матиме можливості залучати кредити на зовнішніх ринках.
Далі, як снігова лавина. Разом із браком інвестицій це спровокує дефіцит валюти в Україні.
А це, у свою чергу, призведе до подорожчання імпортних товарів і спекулятивних цін на вітчизняні.
Ціни зростуть фактично на все і в рази: від бензину до апельсинів.
Інвестори залишатимуть країну, а люди втрачатимуть робочі місця.
Україні просто не довірятимуть.
Репутаційні втрати доведеться відновлювати роками, якщо не десятиліттями.
Навіть у 2014-му та 15-му роках під час анексії Криму та найактивнішої фази російської агресії на Донбасі
Україна не оголошувала дефолт. І нині це буде просто нелогічно.
Останнім часом в Україні вже відбувається певне економічне зростання
і зменшення боргового навантаження.
За оцінками економістів, зараз немає жодної вагомої причини, щоб оголошувати дефолт.
Чотири роки тому Греція стала першою розвиненою країною,
яка не повернула Міжнародному валютному фонду суттєву частину кредиту.
Але проводити паралелі з Україну зовсім некоректно.
За словами експертів, це був не стільки дефолт Греції, скільки значна реструктуризація її боргу,
який тепер доведеться виплачувати наступні 40 років.
Тим паче, Греція - не просто країна-член ЄС, а входить до єврозони.
Тож, рятували не тільки країну, а і ситуацію з курсом євро.
Україна - в іншій ваговій категорії.
Мало хто за Україну вступиться і залучати кошти після дефолту буде значно дорожче.
Багато банків стануть банкрутами, а вкладники втратять свої депозити.
Рівень інфляції зашкалюватиме.
При цьому багаті стануть ще багатшими, а бідні ще біднішими, стверджують економісти.
Різноманітні активи в Україні, включаючи державне майно, значно подешевшають,
й олігархи матимуть можливість скупити їх фактично задарма.